when you're talking about you know
things that you look back in the past
and you shame yourself and you're like
oh I did this I'm a bad person I'm I
regret that I it's all these things and
when you start talking about them you
realize like we don't we're not born
into this world and we just are all
perfect we're we're all flawed and
that's just a reality and you are going
to do things that you know you look back
and you go oh my God if anybody knew
that they would think I'm just not a
nice person or if I'm not but you know
you're it's all about the
uh it's all about the end game right
like if you evolve that's the goal is to
evolve to not be that's the win that's
the win so you know if you know I was a
certain way when I was younger it's it's
not who I become today and who I'm
becoming it's um so therapy has taught
me a lot about how to you know love
myself how to light myself to you know
to look in the mirror and go hey dude
you're a good guy you're a good guy you
do good things sometimes you're dick
right you didn't need to say that you
didn't need to say the dick part you
just say you love yourself and you know
do you do you do are you good to
yourself do you love
yourself I know I know You' probably
talked about it already but just so I
have context when did you start going to
therapy how old were you right after you
didn't go out with me again I think God
no no everybody's like oh shut up Rosen
bom enough with that no honestly
I think I went through this breakup
where it was my fault and I tried to get
her
back and it didn't
happen and I just it was devastating and
I know that I caused it it was my
fault and
so I one of my friends suggested like
you should talk to someone I'm like well
what are they going to I what am I going
to do I went through a break oh poor me
but no but people go through this this
this is what you have to you need it's
nice to talk to someone objectively and
just say hey I feel this emptiness I
don't want to do anything I lost my
appetite I I can't stop I'm obsessive
thinking about this and you know and I
I've was never I've never been the guy
where I was like ever checking up on
someone or show like not weird [__] it
was just in my head I just felt like
[__] you carried it yeah I carried it
and it took a while to get rid of that
and just talking to someone for an hour
and I a lot of times Ryan here I got him
into therapy but you know we start we
think I don't want to go [__] I don't
want to talk I'm not in the mood I'm G
to cancel this I'll eat the hundred
bucks or whatever the [__] it is and
I'll just I'm not going to do it today I
don't I have nothing to talk about and
then all of a sudden you you start
talking and uh all of a sudden you're
like holy [__] I got five minutes left I
still want to get into this I want every
time you're you just letting things out
kind of clears a little bit of that you
know a little bit of your mind so you
know and I'm a natural talker I can go I
can I I had to also realize that I
can like there's certain like I was I
would lean on friendships a lot and so
that's where I also had to you know
check myself in adulthood is really
making sure I had a place where I could
go that also wasn't like oh let me
release all this weight that I'm
carrying and be like here you organize
it yeah like you know you Marie condo it
for me um you know where I had to kind
of take responsibility and do that so it
didn't affect other friendships and
relationships of mine um but the other
thing I'll say that I always like to say
for anyone that listens and is like well
I'm never going to go to or I tried
therapy once and it didn't work out for
me is like it's not what that's not one
siiz fits-all either you know it it is
you if you go to a therapist and you
don't like the way they do therapy like
you should always make a few
appointments like you know a a lot of
therapists will offer like potentially a
free introduction you know session or
change therapist if you don't feel the
vibe just change it change therapist
it's not your fault if it doesn't work
out it's no and if they're a good
therapist they should say like
absolutely like let me know if you need
any recommendations hope you find
someone anyone who tries to guilt you
into staying like is usually not a good
not a good no I had one guy I left him
years ago I went to him probably handful
of times and cuz one of my friends went
to him he's like he's really good and
it's like the third session the guy's
like eating a Subway sandwich while he's
talking to me in the room he's just
eating a Subway sandwich I'm sorry I
haven't had lunch are you okay with that
I'm like no do I have a choice have a
choice well you're hungry what am I
going to say no and then it's awkward
for the next hour but you're just you're
picking out on this [__] sandwich do
you have to put so much Mayo on there
it's on your [__]
lips so yeah um no one looks
professional eating a sub boy sandwich
it is
no